[intense music]
Come on.
OK.
Now you got fish.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
I'm on the Tornio River,
and I've finally
caught something.
It's a fish, right, Marcu?
No, it's not fish, but stone.
There are only stone there.
Damn.
I thought had one, then.
Yeah.
Come on, baby.
[intense music]
GORDON RAMSAY
(VOICEOVER): The river is
clearly not in a giving mood.
Maybe today is
not my lucky day.
Yeah.
Listen, what I'd love to do--
If you don't
mind, is taste one.
Yeah.
And we have a special way
to cook this whitefish.
That's hard.
Yeah.
A lot harder than you think.
Exactly.
It's quite unique to
be given a chance to fish
with this family because only
a few families have the rights
to fish along these banks.
So a unique experience.
I just hate going
home empty handed.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
Marcu has asked
his friend Kimmo teach
me the traditional way
to cook whitefish.
We're gonna taste it in here.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
This being Finland,
it obviously involves
a very warm wooden hut.
Hello.
How are you?
Oh, Kimmo.
Kimmo, nice to see you.
Gordon.
Wow, this is beautiful.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
So traditionally, they're all
cooked on sticks like that?
Yeah, this is traditional way.
Couple hundred years.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER): The
fish are rested for 24 hours
before they're cooked and then
put on this open fire to roast.
He's turning them
round every, what,
every three or four minutes?
Yeah.
Once they're colored?
That's amazing.
And what are you
seasoning them with?
What's the seasoning?
Just natural.
No.
Nothing before.
Nothing at all.
Wow.
Hello.
Well, let me show.
Golden.
Wow.
That's golden.
This is ready.
They're ready.
It's crispy.
What's he putting in there?
Yeah.
This is--
What is that?
Very strong salt water.
And that's the only
way you prepare it.
And after it's ready.
So he cools them down
in the salted water?
Yeah.
GORDON RAMSAY
(VOICEOVER): The saltwater
prevents them from cooking any
further and flavors the fish.
What an amazing technique.
They look incredible.
The smell--
Yeah.
-- is amazing.
Kimmo, how do you
know they're cooked?
[speaking finnish]
He has a thermometer
on his finger.
Right.
He's got therm--
You've made the skin
almost like bacon.
It's crispy.
Yeah.
Not too hard.
No.
But not too soft.
Got a beautiful color.
Crispy.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER):
Maybe it's the chef in me,
but I can't stand by and
watch Kimmo do all the work
without offering a hand.
Kimmo, do you
want them turned?
Yeah?
Which ones?
This.
Turn that one.
And this.
Man.
Ah?
It's the water.
It's ready.
In?
And next one.
[bleep] You got to move fast
because all of a sudden--
Crispy.
This one?
You start off with nothing,
and then they're all going.
This one?
Check.
That's helpful, hey.
[speaking finnish]
Yes.
Fast, fast.
Coming up.
[speaking finnish]
Oh.
That one.
Go, go.
[bleep] Go fast.
This one?
Oh, [bleep].
Oh.
[bleep]
Last two.
Kimmo, two to go.
Yeah?
One each, because
you've done no--
you've done no work.
Yeah.
You just stood there.
Yeah, I'm--
Yes.
But I am the fisherman, too.
Yeah.
[bleep]
Really?
Seriously?
Last one.
Look at that.
Great.
[gentle music]
Kimmo.
Oh.
Please may we eat now?
Yes.
Thank you.
God, look how white that is.
Oh?
No, there's no bone.
Mm.
[speaking finnish]
Oh my goodness, me.
It doesn't need salt, Kimmo.
It is really delicious.
Honestly.
It's the only village you
can get it in the world.
Really?
Yeah.
I've eaten a lot of fish in
my life, sometimes with chips.
But that on its
own is delicious.
And it's given me a lot of
inspiration for the final cook
at the end of the week.
And I'd love for both of you
to join us at the final cook.
Really?
OK.
Now, would you do
me a favor and go out
and get some fish for the
cook at the end of the week?
Yeah.
Let's say, I do
immediately after this.
Will you catch any this time?
Yeah.
For sure.
Delicious.
Thank you.
Great job.
What an amazing fish.
Delicious.
It's definitely
given me inspiration
now for the final cook.
Don't get too clever
with this white fish.
First of all, I'm going to
have to follow that technique
and cook over wood, otherwise
if you start filleting it,
cooking it skin side
down, nonstick pan,
you're going to get
absolutely slaughtered.
So keep it simple, but a nice
little find, the whitefish.
[thoughtful music]